so he's doing a little homework for this
and I hear you're a horror movie fan I
love it yeah I can talk about our movies
all day long and I feel like the to go
to questions with that is first what is
the first term of you ever saw gremlins
I was 10 or 9 10 9 turning 10
uh I begged my mom to let me watch it
and she finally let me watch it and let
me tell you I was freaked out my mom
went to the bathroom for a little break
and I screamed out why did you do that I
thought she got eaten by a gremlin
understandable that was a very good one
to start with yeah what is the scariest
movie you've seen thus far us and it but
that's why they're my favorites okay I
we're two very different really I would
definitely get behind both of those yeah
data might give you any movies other
than the shining to prep for this no um
it was we really just stuck to the
script and then I watched The Shining
four times so it was really a basic
foundation and I grew from there did you
ever read the doctor sleep book I read
some of it yes um it was very heavy but
I did my best to get a grip on Avril
okay I think you definitely achieved
that have you read any other Stephen
King books I'm reading the stand now oh
my god I would love to see that on the
screen I mean I don't know why that was
like one of the last ones I thought you
would say that's like quickly
undertaking no it's so interesting I
love the characters and the story is
just oh I highly recommend the Institute
I'm reading it I'm reading it
so there's an arrow in it that they're
gonna adapt it any day now and you need
to be in them I really think that's the
case yeah so with this movie now I'm
curious was there any particular scene
where on the schedule you circled it and
said on that day I'm gonna be the most
nervous cuz you're working with such
cool people doing such big set pieces I
can imagine there's a whole bunch of
answers I mean not really I would circle
them and say I'm excited for that day
let's do this but sometimes I would get
a little overwhelming because I was new
too
but having mr. Yin and Miss Rebecca
there was a real treat yeah it was a
real comfort they were kind of like my
mentors my podium like gems they are
they're amazing what about just with a
Brazil ''tis did that make any of the
scenes really complicated because it's
not like she and Rose can stand there
and you know face-to-face fist fight
they're doing all this crazy stuff um it
was a lot of fun I got to use my
imagination alive and really worked off
of that so it wasn't that hard to just
imagine what was going on and I'm sure
with someone as visual and someone with
an editing background like Mike actually
that probably really helps you out oh
yeah definitely when I saw it all put
together I was like wow how did he do
without maybe spoiling anything too big
is there any particular scene that when
you saw it in its final version you're
like whoa I didn't know it looked like
that um definitely definitely when I
press can detract about was one thing
that like I don't think I ever could
have envisioned anything like that okay
yeah I was on a wire and there was a
blue screen window frame and I was so
excited cuz I felt like I was flying
sequence was one of my favorite
sequences in the entire film yay did you
come up with an opera playlist well I
mean I cut a little I'm sure she'd have
a lot of vintage songs a lot of Elvis
Presley maybe some let me think
Jack's rubber um she'd listened to a
bunch she's gotta have like the longest
playlist ever probably I mean she's
always listening to music some Beyonce
first so yeah obviously mm-hmm you
actually listened to anything in any
scenes
um no sadly I think I think a Burwood
mainland listen to Billy Eilish that
probably I would probably share a very
similar place Avril but what about just
taking cool things home from the shoot
with you did you get to keep anything
didn't I lost a few things though Lord
you my golden cat's cradle in a burrs
backpack I really wanted to take home
her coat though that coat is pretty
awesome yeah what about little details
in her room we do get to learn a lot
about her but I always feel like in a
character's bedroom set there's always
these little things that tell
a little more about the person well she
has a lot of Ruby figures that I was so
jealous up I really wanted them and then
there's her little bunny her little
bunny there her bunny her art supplies
there's a lot of everyn